hello everyone and welcome to a nice
style game which you all know what it
means it means that we are commemorating
yet another successfully reached
milestone as of today this channel is
counting 400,000 subscribers I think
you'll for that you are all excellent
subscribers if by any chance you are not
you are more than welcome to join and
well a lot of you have been suggesting
that some talk games for me to show and
you've been saying that I've been owing
you a game by Tao we already seen three
games towel versus near Modena of where
an acquaintance of won all three games
that we've shown but he did have the
white pieces in all of them and so you
were saying show us the 4th game they
played but I still have started to save
that one for another opportunity and I
will not be showing that game today but
I've prepared another very nice game
it's against me Lisa
Brockman is a very strong Latvian chess
player who I believe at the time this
game was played was that at the strength
of a candidate master and he doesn't
have a lot of games in the database
broccolis has only two games available
in the database one against min Hotel
another one against Vladimir petrol so
holy two games in the database and both
against well soviet legends so to say
and i also would like to take this
opportunity to remind everyone that not
so long ago i also had a well a regular
nine-to-five job where I would have a
normal day at Woking then I would rush
home to make my videos and I always
liked at every milestone that we reach I
always like to invite everyone to check
out my video where I was commemorating
when the channel reached 1000
subscribers just you know for you to
check out the quality of the video the
well the everything and how the channel
evolved over time so the first thing you
will see in the description below will
be a nice tall game at all versus to it
in really a wonderful game not bad for a
dead man it was called I still didn't
know at that time why it was called that
but feel free to check it out it's a
wonderful game and a wonderful way for
you to see how how the channel really
evolved over time and also I will put
all the three games tile played and
against ninja matino there we already
shown it on the channel the second third
and fourth the link in the description
below so feel free to check that out as
well so that one day when we
finally show the fourth game towel
played against newsmen you know that you
will be ready and also for tomorrow
before we check out this very nice game
I would like to announce a very nice
livestream it will be starting at 6 p.m.
Central European Time we'll have a
nicely chess tournament with some prizes
maybe starting at 6 36 645 maybe we will
see how it goes and it will ask for some
two hours the time control will be two
plus zero as well
if prizes are involved any any longer
time controls would just be invitations
for for cheaters and we can have that so
that's that then we're gonna have some
nice fun no feel free to bring your own
jokes as we always do have those I will
be accompanied by by a guest for the
stream as usual and we'll be giving away
some prizes this time I decided not to
go with the chess set as it's really
hard to ship a chess set so instead I
decided to give away Amazon gift cards
you know maybe maybe 10 or 15 of them
depending I still have to figure it out
but to enter the giveaway the most
important thing for you to do is leave a
comment on this video regarding Michael
Tao so anything about Michael Tao what
you enjoy what you don't enjoy what you
would have enjoyed doesn't really matter
any comment that has hashtag tall in it
will enter the giveaway and as usual we
will be choosing the winners with I
would a random winner generator website
that I will choose on random let's say
spam that's about it for a for informing
you about about tomorrow and for today
this is the game I've chosen its towel
versus Brock bonus and it's played in
1959 I do hope you enjoy it let's check
it out
so tau opens with the white pieces he
plays efore we have E 5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 and Bishop to c4 and we
have Bishop to c5 so the Italian game is
on the board and we have before this is
the Evans gambit but it was not played
in this game even though it's it's an
excellent opening it wasn't played here
or was it maybe well the yes it was it
was played in this game here tau
actually did
play before he went for the Evans gambit
and this is one of the two games where
tall really plays the Evans gambit with
the white pieces and Brockman is accepts
the challenge he plays Bishop character
son before grab some material and allows
tile to start advancing his pawns in the
center so we have C 3 a normal response
where you go for the Evans gambit were
black and choose Bishop a5 maybe Bishop
c5 much rarer move Bishop d6 or Bishop
to e7 you know a lot of theory behind
each of these moves in the game Bishop
to e7 is played Anderson's defense or I
believe it's also the the Hungarian line
of the of the Evans gambit and here you
can choose a lot of different ways to go
about it all goes immediately d4 just
waiting to see if black will go for more
material maybe Queen b3 going for B's f7
will be played and here indeed you can
go a capture some d4 Queen b3 and Knight
a5 a very sharp line our black is
threatening the knight and the bishop
and the Queen also white can capture on
f7 but after King f8 you can go Queen a4
and then again a lot of things can
happen but it wasn't played in this game
here after toss d4 we have just Knight
to f6 a Brockman is all first all to
capture on e5 and there is no better
move tall does go for this with D
captures on e5 Knight to g4 now and tall
takes this opportunity to immediately
threatened checkmate Queen d5 threatens
Queen captures on f7 checkmate Brockman
is castles and what's the idea now h3 of
course you force the knight back to h6
we have Knight to h6 and now Tao could
capture an h6 bust open the King with
the G captures in age 6 but there's
there's a there's time for this I mean
there's no rush the knight isn't really
going anywhere and talking just you know
use this opportunity to get his King to
safety to develop pieces and to figure
out where to go from there
so here tall castles which maybe ideas
like Knight d4 f4 f5 depending on what
black plays black goes for d6 it's a
very nice principled move you do want to
keep on developing your pieces you want
to attack white center the bishop now
has a has a pathway to to be developed
and he captures on d6 by Tao we have C
captures and ESA's Queen captures on d6
is also an option to immediately offer a
queen trade but barackman is is playing
like like a champ against all he's not
interested in trading queens and tacos
Queen to h5 now with the threat of
Bishop captures on h6
pawn captures and followed by Queen
captures on h6 and you really have to
figure out how to do this you still
can't move your night so you could go
for an extremely sharp line with Bishop
to e6 or what what happened in the game
Queen to a5 now we have queen staring at
each other
we'll talk trade queen stall isn't
interested taco is a Bishop to d5
against again keeping the bishop
captures on h6 as an option in the game
so first Bishop to e6 and now you don't
have time to capture on h6 if you
capture on h6 now do you see what
Brockman is had in mind or even feel
free to pause the video here to figure
out how he planned to go about this I'll
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
Queen trapper and for those if you just
wanna enjoy a show here Brockman is had
g6 planned and here toss queen is trap
nowhere to go or the bishops are slicing
nicely all the way here all of these
squares are covered and while you could
go for a queen sacrifice with yet Bishop
captures on a fade
the problem is after G captures on a
fire on h5 Bishop captures on c6
removing the defender of these 7 bishop
but a black will first get capture on f8
rook captures here and then okay Bishop
captures b7 but then just lets a Bishop
f6 and you don't really have great
compensation for the Queen you have a
piece and the rook which which is nice
but it's not it's not enough so after
Bishop to e6
tall of course doesn't capture tau goes
rook sorryto goes rook to d1
just improving the defense of the bishop
here now Bishop captures rook can
capture the Queen
trade is still off the board look after
I ate by Brock - and now Bishop to 4
call simply continues developing and
Luke 8 to d8 all of the both of the
blacks rooks are now in the game night
beat
d - you still have to figure out how to
develop here the knight is defending the
pawn and c3 but you know this is no time
to be you know keeping an eye on your
pawns
so here tog was the knight Knight B to
d2 gives up the c3 pawn and his opponent
captures it you have to see also that if
you want to alleviate the pressure here
by maybe grabbing a few pieces of the
board would be Bishop captures on d5
white can just go phone captures and
then after Knight here just Knight
captures D captures and Bishop captures
on e6 and now there's really no danger
from g6 as black no longer has a light
square bishop so you will not be able to
trap the Queen you will have to capture
here and then just c4 and white you know
has an excellent position so after
Knight bTW - we have Queen captures and
c3 by black now with the idea of going
back with Queen to f6 you know grabbing
opponent just helping out with the
defense of the King and now Todd takes
this opportunity and goes g4 so g5 is
the idea where the knight would be
trapped and black has to figure out how
to go about this black quickly rushes
back with the Queen we have Queen to f6
now again with the idea that the g5 is
played the Queen captures and f4 is
possible but it's a line that you have
to consider for example if g5 Queen
captures on f/4g captures on h6 doesn't
work because again g6 trap stalls Queen
on on h5 so not an option and you can
see how bravely Bachman is is playing
against all accepting the attendee Evans
gambit then declining the Queen trade
and then still playing like really
really you know really impressive table
goes back Bishop to e3 and now Bishop
captures on d5 with he captures on d5
and only now Knight to e5 threatening to
capture the knight on f3 as both the
knight and the Queen are attacking it so
here Todd has the trade with Queen
Knight captures on e5 Queen captures on
e5 and here at all has the freight
Queens Queen captures on e5 d captures
on e5 and now only Bishop captures on h6
only now the star give up the bishop for
the night to mess up the pawn structure
in front in front of
like the black King G captures on h6 and
now Knight to e4 and here's the problem
that black faces you don't really have a
good way of stopping the past pawn d6 is
coming you can't block with the Bishop
Knight f6 check picks up the rook so
what can you do here Brockman is played
King to g7 okay you have fermented the
knight from entering the f6 Square but
here tall just goes d6
advancing the D pawn attacking the
bishop and you have to go back Bishop to
f8 is played and now Todd was rook a to
see one with with hopes of reaching the
c7 square and if if this is possible
then it should be very good for tall now
if you play something like rook to c8
trying to prevent it this way then of
course d7 wins the game straight away
and if you don't if you play something
that was played in the game rook to d7
not all just improves the position of
the king we have King to g2 rook eat d8
now with a triple attack against the d6
pawn and stall has no ways of bringing
yet a third defender to the wards the d6
pawn but it's also not a problem because
White has an even better move so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the idea or a towel plate here it's the
only move that really gives a white
further advantage so I'll give you a
couple of seconds while you ponder on
the position for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are a
excellent and excellent endgame player
and for those if you just want to
enjoyed show top plate rook the c7 and
now you see the problem the problem is
you can't win the d6 pawn because if you
capture it then you get rook captures
rook captures and of course row capture
son b6 you will be down a whole piece
and of course you will lose this game on
the other hand if you play rook captures
rook on c7
then you get D captures on c7 word if
you capture on d1 then white will just
bring a queen into the game it's game
over and if you block it with rook to c8
now tal had in mind look to d7 defending
the pawn and now doesn't really matter
what you play here for example you could
go a six but now the night it just has
to get to the b6
for example might can come to c3 than 2a
for them to b6 or if the a four square
is blocked to d5 then to b6 kick away
the rook force the rook to trade on c7
and it's game over one such line could
be the knight c3 b5 preventing Knight
from reaching a four but then comes
Knight d5 and here you don't really have
a good option night is coming to b6 the
rook will be kicked away you will have
to give up the look for the pawn and
then white will be winning or on the
other hand if you try it Bishop c5
taking care of the b6 square then you no
longer control the the back rang just
root d8 the knife controls the c7 point
and it's all over you will either trade
and white gets a queen or you will
capture and then tonight captures you
are down a whole rook of course tau is
winning the same game
so rooks e7 a very powerful move but
here Brockman is played b6 just you know
improving the position of his pawns rook
captures on a7 is impossible because
rook will just capture it so here tall
has to figure it out here tell just
plays rook to d3 and here black has to
figure out what to do if you play
something like f6 just you know try to
keep everything together then table will
go rock a3 go after the a7 pawn this way
if a5 is played then he's gonna go back
route b3 go after the beef b6 pawn
slowly but surely tars rook will gobble
up all of the Queen side pawn so black
can't really afford to waste time here
black tried a different idea now that
the rookies on d3 black indeed tried
rook captures on c7 we have D captures
on c7 Luke the c8 a similar idea like in
the previous line but after roof to d7
here Bishop to b4 is played so again
feel free to pause the video and try to
figure out how tal went about this
position again I'll give you a couple of
seconds as it is a very nice game for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player you've you're you are finding
move by move that McHale towel played
here top plate a3 he just wants to kick
away that Bishop get get the C 3 square
available for his Knight and you don't
really have a good way of preventing
this you could go Bishop a5 but doesn't
really help you yes you still control c3
but then what can
go to d6 kick away the rook this way so
instead after a 3-bike decided okay I
have to capture the pawn he played
Bishop characters on a3 and now finally
tall has the c3 square for his knight
but black planned all of this out as
you've already seen
broccolis is a very strong player he
decided to give up the rook for two
connected passed pawns he played a five
here and okay we have Knights to b5
attacking the bishop preparing Knight d6
or Knight 287 does really matter the
rook will be you know won by white
Bishop to b2 and now comes Knight to d6
and here black no longer has any options
he has the capture on c7 rook captures
on c7 is played rook captures on c7 and
now a 4 here Brock - well of course
hoping for a 3 a 2 and a 1 but tal has
everything planned out we have Knight to
f5 check not bothering with real
characters on f7 this would be way too
slow just Knight to f5 check here black
went King to G sub the King to g6 and
here talent looked the c6 check we have
now f6 blocking the check from the rook
and again feel free to pause the video
here and for the third time in this
video
try to figure out what Tull played here
and why this is such a nice game I'll
give you a couple of seconds once again
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have yet again found
a very nice idea at all played and for
those of you who just won't enjoy the
show if you found rook captures and b6
congratulations you are winning this
game but it's not it's not the nicest
way to go about this position if you
find rook to c7 then really
congratulations this is what all played
and now black really doesn't have any
options if black just continues pushing
happily his past pawn then Tom replies
with rook to g7 and this is checkmate of
course the row covers g5 the pawn covers
all of these squares and the King has
nowhere to go so of course black tried
to avoid this brockman is played King to
g5 but it doesn't matter of course now
he does have an escape route came to a4
or King to h4
but top late King to g3 and now the King
has no longer
any squares left left do you know try
and escape to whatever black plays any
move there really isn't a way even for
black to prolong this game any move
black makes let's say three towel will
just go rook to g7 and it's game over
it's checkmate and and what I want a
wonderful checkmate it is so really a
wonderful game where towel played the
evans game but like i said it's one of
the two games in taos entire career that
Todd used the Evans gambit probably not
I mean he surely used it in blitz games
maybe in bullet games and of the all the
record games but in in official games
two games are available in the database
where the word hall used the Evans
gambit so it's a really impressive game
Brockman's accepts the challenge then
offers a queen trait tall declines it
then Brockman is can once again go for
the Queen trade but then he declines it
and then he finally is able to trade
down to an end game but which the end
game that is already lost and tall just
finds the easiest and the nicest way to
go to go about it Sam a wonderful Evans
game by Michael Tao I do hope you
enjoyed it and once again I do do leave
a comment if you are interested in
entering the giveaway hash tag tile plus
any comment about Michael towel to be
able to win some prizes some MS Amazon
gift cards you know you could buy an ice
chest book and buy pretty much anything
you want a Bobby Fischer action figure
if if they have started creating those I
don't know that they really should have
but in a way you know we're gonna have a
lot of fun tomorrow so make sure you
join in
don't forget 6:00 p.m. Central European
Time you know prepare some chest jokes
we're gonna have some maybe some you
know something some beer even maybe I
maybe some cake you know so should be a
lot of fun join the elite chess
tournament should be as there will be
prizes there should be a lot of title
players so there will be a lot of
challenge even even climbing up to the
top 100
I believe Sam that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it do check out my video
where I come and furnished my channel
reaching 1000 subscribers it will be the
first link in the description below and
then three games tall versus measurement
you know the the the three links that
follow so you will be
when I finally present the four became
tall ever played against Russia Deshmukh
Dino's but him I would like to thank
Federico samhita Ludovic Laurent CC bass
pro Stefan Green and George Taylor for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon we'll see with some perhaps
continuing the capablanca saga or
checking up on some of your suggestions
and of course with tomorrow's three I
think y'all I will see you soon have an
excellent rest of your day